これじゃあ肇社長です比嘉妓生に泣かされ
たらどういう反応セローアワー
泣き落とします汁で私初めて増今からです
ね日限り産地もうすぐしたらいーくんです
けれども僕の流れとをつけるの中私を持っ
たのはヒカキンさんですねで起こったりし
て人を泣かせたああっ噴火実はあるみたい
なソースまでからちゃうわけですよただ
ひとつ言えることはあの人はいい人たちを
とってもまずしてきますですが優しいとか
じゃなくてすごいしっかりされているから
その人のために何かこう言ったり接客する
ことあると思うんですけどもむやみに人を
抱かせることは絶対ない人なんですよあの
人ということで私は思いました辰巳社長の
党府議というかこのな特殊能力の一つとし
て感受性がヒット500倍高いコレ一つ
南北のポイントなんですけれども肝臓医療
がすごいしやすくて結構ねどんな状況でも
あるトリガーが発動すれば確実に泣けるん
ですよトリガーっていうのは結構あの
変わるんですけども最近僕が出音何回見て
もない様とがありまして今のアニメ
ポケットモンスターの千秋役てるから政治
家だったエピソード118サトシ出陣 vs
第5ピースの daigo って知って
ましたのポケモンルビーサファイア
エメラルドのホウエン地方のチャンピオン
醍醐ですよめちゃ狂っめっちゃ強いです
けども常に作動して二つの物語が最終局面
ということでチャンピオンと戦うせを
いろんな
10がもう本当にね分かる関東つオーキド
博士からピカチュウ今仲良くなってから
ずっと長いメッシがあって今も本当中で
ファイナルというか宝探しの冒険の集大成
みたいなでもぷりも何もずっと見てきてる
んですよサトシのピカチュウの思い出の技
とか使って勝負するちょっとぞ
文だけます1階にいますねそれ前サトシと
ピカチュウに完全にして泣けるんですよ
染みますねやばいのがサイバーのアニメで
四女だぜと希望マスター流れるんですよ
まさかの目指せほとんどされるんだよ
[音楽]
んあああああ
ああああああが入ってますねハッ
ハー
うやばーい
無効とがございてるんですよね
俳優買った年とピカチュウが冒険した
あろう落差方っていうのがあるんですね
サームーンとそこで z 字っていうね
その全力の技をできてさとしておきたちが
覚えてやろうな仲間たちの思い出とかも
全部俺あに売ってるからどうよぎると
すごいが2戸3日数を受けしてもの強い
ポケモンじゃないようによくそんな
チャンピオンと張り合って戦えるなって
思うとなんか
ずっとアニメよっても生きたらなんか
なければいいなって思ってそういう話じゃ
ないんです今日ははいというわけでこんな
感じて豊かな牧夫鍵井さんのお家に行って
もたぶん今だったら大後で見たらだけれど
で
怖いともですよヒカキンさん突然落ちに来
て突然外れ者と敵出すとどう見ても惹か
キーさんが原因だとか兄さんに流されたと
いうことになると思うので僕は今から擬似
的に限り先に泣かされていきますそれで
ヒカキンさんからするとえなんで泣いてる
んだ俺何か悪いことしたかなとかいろんな
どっ出てくると思う話して肇社長が一科技
山のせいで突然泣き出したらあの方はどう
するでしょうか早速何気に入って皆さん
あああっ
pikake さ直しにつきましたさすが
に生えていくと思いますん
ん
ます彼はですん
すかを使ったねそう私は保存します
なんつーかが多い聞いてはいけません
落丁普通に話しますまぁ久々ですねを編集
されてるんですね
一つねもう夏も本番なんで寝ます
やっぱりそうだしているそうだねたら夏前
に頑張っておいた貯金がちょっとあるって
言うなはい
編集とかが
たそうじゃってる家が何そっちばっかり
よかった
いい企画持ってきましたエアーウェーブ
編集溜まっていると思ったねー
今日は一緒に
英智ジョブーブ
[拍手]
ちょっニャー
死んじゃってん
一緒にちょっと編集したいが凍っています
ここで編集しなくね
[音楽]
[拍手]
がんばれなぜ結構もうになっちゃうけどあ
全然全然もを走って
pastor 回までも前々日の広に
触れるのは素晴らしいん
まあまあ
スーパ
[音楽]
ん
ううっうぅ
[音楽]
うう坊
ブーバー
し
[音楽]
年の差
ゲームしてんじゃないだろうなあー
ちょっと今だからゲームというから
ちょっとだけ作業
ブーッ
デス v 系中に言われたやつですね
[音楽]
goo
4分
[音楽]
me
ああああああああ
[音楽]
よろし良いついてゴッ
元文書の病院たらいいなんはぁっ
[音楽]
ええええええええええええ
第2me
[音楽]
canんだろ
動画年収が続いている
限界が来たみたいです
んです
を破っ
俺たちで p
ぼやく者が逸れました
ね出世のナチュラル1技も喋ってるバッハ
なんとなくわかったよ何を知っ公康
してだ花粉ができ
大好きな多分アニメが何かで感動してい
ないという
いやお役に泣かされました
対等と解するか2も uf 文章よ子って
られましたね
はっはっは
[音楽]
いっきまーさー
不況
[音楽]
ブーブーれないじゃんこれ途中で予想した
あーこちゃん
ヌードル
[音楽]
hustle
じぇーっ
[音楽]
ブーブー基本何もずっと見てて二つと諭す
の主体型なんでまだ拡散してるの
ああああああああ
たしてもこれずっと見てたらアニメの時も
ずっと見ていて今までの思い出とか全部
よみがえってきたっ
水を飲んでいまでを吸うと人気な理由が
ちょっと1キサンチン突然って泣いて
みよっ
泣いたらどういう反応するのかなと思って
ないってみます
5分
[音楽]
ブーバー1軒か行ってきたから泣いてる
もんねやっ
イヤー
ぬーんね毎回ねーかそこからもう演技が
始まってたのかこれがスマホなしで泣け
たら俳優でしたねっ麻生がなかったそっか
そうだてもいいなぁと思った u さんは
すごいですよ考えず値上げ分は
ちっねーっ環境あるとなかなかなきゃっ
麻生夏美なぁとちょっとそっちおっ聞い
なっちゃ動かしてた注意を買った俺も持っ
てみた方がいいのかなタイヤ設けくらい
いる見なかったおかげで集中できたら何
ですかってちょっと進んでるから
夏と生者に次はもっと泣けるよね5秒鮭
ないとやっぱり高評価
[音楽]
ブーバー
し